and speaking of democrats pushing much
needed legislation
this week several uh democratic
uh members in the house of
representatives
and in the senate have pro proposed
excuse me legislation
called the right to vote act
and what the right to vote act which
let's
give credit here you got representative
mondaire jones
uh senators john office and alex padilla
they introduced this piece of
legislation on wednesday what it would
do
is uh would ensure that courts respect
the right to vote
as the fundamental right that it is it
is the first congressional guarantee of
the right to vote in federal elections
it also solves the problem that we are
seeing in certain states of election
subversion
the bill would affirm americans right to
vote by declaring election laws or rules
that pose a severe or discriminatory
burden
to be illegitimate unless the
jurisdiction in question can prove
that it that its proposed law or rule
furthers a governmental interest
and is the least restrictive means of
doing so
so once again we have democrats
in the house and in the senate
that are saying we have to do something
to protect the right to vote for
americans
you know what is it close to 200 pieces
of legislation being worked on across
the country
we all know texas right now is trying to
be the latest to pass a massively
restrictive voting bill
george has already done it florida's
already done it other states
are trying to get it done as well
federal legislation could circumvent
this
federal legislation could render all of
these other pieces
dead here's
the problem
in some of the areas where this
legislation has passed
and i'm not saying this would be
effective i'm just saying this is a
possibility
you have states that have already passed
these restrictive voting bills
if the federal government were to come
out
with federal legislation basically
undoing these state bills
the states would actually have a pretty
decent 10th amendment case to bring
against the government
you know you didn't have a law in place
so we put our own in place and so ours
existed prior to yours it may not be the
strongest legal argument
but i guarantee you we would see it
coming out of these states you know the
state's rights groups
would be fighting this tooth and nail
doesn't mean it would be successful it
just means if something like
the right to vote act did end up passing
it would still have a long journey
through the u.s
courts before finally becoming law of
the land to be honest
or possibly even being struck down by
the united states supreme court
that as we all know has a huge
conservative slant right now
but all of that is future talk and
there's a time for future talk
and there's a time to just acknowledge
that yes
democrats are actually working to do
good things for the united states
and sometimes you just got to take a win
when you can get a win
and sometimes that win is just the draft
legislation
whether it's the right to vote act
whether it's that
you know 500 billion dollar fine
that sanders and warren want to levy
against fossil fuel companies
a win is a win corey bush
with her protest essentially to extend
the eviction moratorium
that worked we may only get an extra 60
days of an eviction moratorium
but direct action produced a result
and democrats are not sitting idly by
some of them because we all know some of
them are
but some of them are not sitting idly by
in washington d.c
watching as republicans strip voting
rights away from
constituents because that's the only way
they can stay in power
they've admitted that too many times
over just the past year
for us to not acknowledge that that is
why this is happening
republicans know that the public changes
demographics shift people's viewpoints
change
look at polling on issues stripped away
from politicians or political parties
and on the issues
america is actually very progressive
that only changes when you attach a
political ideology or a specific
politician to the policy by the way
something to to keep in mind when you
see these numbers americans support
these things republicans support these
things
they support the infrastructure bill
they support action to
to rain in climate change they support
raising taxes on corporations
the wind is at your back democrats i
want to see
more of this not just because i want you
to prove that you can fight
but because i actually have a vested
interest as an american
in watching everybody's lives get better
i'm faring cousins and for david pakman
we'll be right back
let's be honest most healthy snack bars
are not
exciting like my live streams and that's
why you should check
out our sponsor monk pack monk pack
keto nut and seed bars are sweet and
delicious
soft and chewy with a big satisfying
crunch
but each bar has just one gram of sugar
two to three net carbs and just
150 calories so it's great for someone
on a keto or low carb diet or even if
you just want a tasty sweet snack
without the sugar
monk pack keto nut and seed bars come in
great flavors like sea salt dark
chocolate
caramel sea salt or caramel you choose
and
peanut butter dark chocolate i always
have a box of these ready to go in my
pantry
which is easy when you do the optional
monthly subscription which also saves
you 10 percent
if you have a sweet tooth this is the
way to indulge without the guilt
whether it's for breakfast or in the car
or after a workout
go to monkpack.com the link is under
this video and you'll save 20
when you use code pacman at checkout